[Música]
o caminho como o vício
por exemplo aqui com dois anos de idade
e não tem preço
tocou minha mãe e minhas mãos meu pai já
cá estava
sempre vivi aqui a causa da morte dos
dois anos de idade em que essa morte
começa de novo
[Música]
francis lai cubra os cabelos não trouxe
nada por isso o que eu venho aqui fazer
é a partilha e é poder realmente pra dar
algumas presenças aquilo que foi meu
percurso que foi de 3 programa trabalho
estudo salienta o papel importantíssimo
pois no dia que seria desta porta pra
fora
mensalmente são as mangas e põe em
prática ou então ficam durante show fica
guardado fica aí na nossa folha e quando
querem porque vocês estão aqui outra vez
eu estou noutra zona de banhos não quita
o pessoal todo discutindo mas não podia
falar de bola e não podia falar que
cortam falar daquilo que eu senti
daquilo que foi o meu percurso e quero
partilhar com os mais velhos vícios pelo
mai porque havia muitas coisas também
faziam esquadrão de humilde projetávamos
fora de nós completamento vândalos forma
nós porque nós ainda vamos ver se ele
fará cola paccola dávamos um
lo
eu posso dizer quase não validado já
consumia drogas na rua do fio e fará
cola instantânea amigos meus que ficaram
ficaram por causa da cláusula
você vê que ficaram e modificaram no
combóio vamos aprender antes commodities
ficaram lá aí no rio
tenho um amigo meu que hoje não têm duas
belas cenas assim por pouco a pouco fui
x pode passar a heroína e depois toca aí
nós policiais durante anos anos angeles
e vocês podem mudar na nossa comunidade
esta foi a pergunta que eu fiz dentro da
cadeia e quando se diz que vai parar aí
o que eu posso mudar a minha história
para que outros consigam não estejam não
tenho que bater com a cabeça na parede
para perceber falar para ele ter medo é
normal ter vergonha normal pedir né não
é vergonha
agora uma das coisas que é importante é
termos caráter e se ninguém nos tira
estar dentro de vocês aí dentro é uma
questão só de fazer as coisas como deve
ser dar os passos em condições fazer
escolhas em condições porque o resto vem
por acréscimo a moda
o objetivo foi tirar o curso de
treinador patada do perto reputar por
dentro para poder passar aquilo que a
missão e em poderão estar os miúdos a
perceberem que o desporto é o melhor
meio para eles poderem sair daquilo que
freqüência daquilo que chama dos ímãs
negativo por cair menos negativos que às
vezes nos puxam e nós não sabemos porque
estamos a ser fechado
ora muito vai ficar quando a gente
consegue negociar as notas espalhadas em
sentar aqui e agora vamos esquecer o
desporto vamos assentar e vamos perceber
porque a escola não está funcionando
o que precisa é julgar gosta de jogar ou
caímos para julgar se descuidar na
escola então aí nós vamos perceber vamos
acompanhar de perto o que é que se passa
em qualquer um não é e qual é a minha
motivação e quais são os passos que o dá
pra poder querer jogar ao domingo e quer
treinar e quer fazer parte do grupo já
conseguiu um dos meus sonhos dos meus
objetivos
uma das coisas que consiga para ter os
meus filhos é tem dois são a melhor
coisa e aqui eu tenho convite de amigos
em um convento porque estava com medo
porque é conjunto do que eu tenho feito
as minhas caminhadas passagem só vocês
não têm ajudado a construir os graus dos
necessitados está aqui que vocês vêem
hoje a escala máxima é a escada
já procurei como com muito sacrifício
colo como com muitas coisas cá atrás mas
nunca mais precárias
estas casas hoje eu tenho um carro atrás
também foi um ponto também não vai
complicar na copa da bola desde sempre
também tem a sony também queria ser o
cravo e também na minha porta voz da cia
era mais tempo tirar aos ricos para dar
aos pobres porque achava que minha vida
era tão tão tão tão tão tão desigual da
vida é
eu nunca pôs alguém porque eu fui santo
nem na copa do amor com sete irmãos
quando minha mãe do rapaz já cá estava
fomos viver com lavagem do bonfim na
altura houve água canalizada via longe
pra ver nada disse que a reforma em casa
eu passei muita forma a minha casa
sempre foi um ponto que sempre quis
viver plataforma os meus amigos chegar à
bola
é brincadeira entre a chinesa
só que cada vez que eu venha viver porta
fora e voltar pra casa com desconforto
era maior porque não me sentia
eu achava aquilo muito muito muito
complicado
então o que eu lembro
todo este meus sonhos para a construção
de uma escada forma o alicerce e com
base tranquilo demandou quando fui para
a escola pela primeira vez achando que
podia estudar o que podia ser mas isso
foi logo no primeiro veículo escolhido
na semana porque por enquanto fica
guardado humana
hoje compreendo que há uma desigualdade
humano não pode rodar com tito ter o
governo bush catarata em fazê lo do ser
humano na sua história a não aceitação
da empresa por eu ser preto
acrescentar o velho conter o enxerga que
não é culpa minha e 90 água promovendo
um havia sim um chapéu de palha toda a
comida vai dar água para povos nome dom
para que pudessem desviar para que
pudéssemos lavar a roupa quando havia
qualquer coisa que havia ficar com o
caminho que esta base de higiene é muito
complicado e havia nenhum tipo criam
central é limpo
o professor tiago isto foi o primeiro
shopping que eu tenho vai pra mim se eu
tinha sonhos se eu conhecer o autor a
partir de hoje eu quero dizer lhe porque
sou torcedor excluir vão já alto
excluído automaticamente
juntei-me voz corrente no youtube
hoje não tenho problema nenhum em falar
de importadoras um tema instigante não
tem alguns prêmios assim garante também
a gente tem alguns países selecionados
não é tamanho que existia
e então o que nós vamos fazer fomos
dentro daquilo que já foi aqui
apresentada das emoções da capacidade
sempre a capacidade de ver pertencer ou
seja nós deixamos proteger
passamos acontecer com o grupo que
possivelmente é compartilhávamos um
sentimento de revolta dentro desta volta
o que fazemos
vamos trabalhar vamos pegar o gestor ou
estragar a oportunidade de completamente
negativo foi a caminhada disso foi a
escada a escada pode ser ainda várias
línguas
eu posso ver como posso dizer o pouso
eu comecei por tiro no rosto os novatos
como você resolver o im já consumia
ocorrem no meu percurso escadaria foi
sempre pra baixo mas a viver na rua
porque eu ia casa sentia completamente
confortável vendo os meus irmãos passado
falta aquela vida não fazia muita
agora pra mim então seria viver pra rua
e um pendente repassar forma ajudam
porque era um dos muitos que o estado
defenderá dos outros mas não fazer outro
mas prefiro passar forma na rua do
banheiro em casa sede na rua domingos de
commodities mas aí quando você estudava
muito estudava a encontrar o seu caminho
é bem observado foi à rua da minha
cidade foi a minha história daquilo que
é o meu foi construída onde é que eu
aprendi que aprender que na rua
o fato muitas vezes incutirem coisas
para a imprensa
gigantes é preenchido frente pra isso e
não o prende quem mandar um abraço o
feto
eu ia cada cigano para não passar frio
escadas
no entanto ele olhava serra chegando até
nós era um companheiro para lá mas
sofreu outro fora
em outro livro atual tem que fazer a
vida toda esta informação
vejo hoje olhar por uma escada de foi
porque o mesmo percurso foi sempre pra
falar eu fui preso como as ações ali
sair em seis meses preso
achando que sabia tudo deixando que era
linda achando que é o maior
enquanto estiver dentro da cadeia
com um ponto o tempo do cliente de outro
tempo pessoas possivelmente ensinar um
degrau a mais é necessário mais um
pouquinho
enquanto isso aí se encontra mesmo
mas pela pt fazendo a minha vida tem
cinco meses já fora preso outra vez e
ainda eram 14 antes do mundial ficou em
10 em 10 anos penso em seguir uma vida
corrida às vezes costumam fazer a
pergunta dos 10 milhões se tivesse
voltar atrás coisa tudo igual
eu tenho que dizer que se calhar o
aumento da violência pelo velho mas já
estava tudo igual
nos dez anos que foi preso
foi uma vida de sofrimento porque podia
ser algo que não pudesse parar como foi
dito aqui uma dela a estrutura contra a
cabeça
o meu foi tempo é dentro do quadrado
prisão eu ainda reduzir o espaço canadá
que o sr eu sempre fui sindicalista
sempre do contra
sempre total e assim assim
estou com vontade de seis meses fechado
durante 23 anos está no poder embora mas
foi isso que aconteceu
conhece a escada que eu escolhi e como
isto para dizer o que no orçamento da
vida a vida é o cruzeiro é iniciação à
vossa vida aconteceu hoje muito vai
comandando a nossa língua
às vezes levo vai às vezes podemos o
time às vezes que temos um papel ainda
contavam com o juventude às vezes
rodasse a ela que saiu reclamando quando
por ela ainda está lá
por isso é importante como já foi dito
aqui se quiserem ser doutores força os
seus autores com caráter
sejam todos com a capacidade humana de
olhar o outro como pessoa
se calhar não só como ninguém porque vão
ter grandes coisas na nossa vida e vou
fazer do outro
agora além da falha que todos nós temos
mas tem aqui alguém que olha blanc
começou eu digo disputa
foi assim que você vai comprar um dia né
cada e chamou pelo meu nome
você é os meus gols de trabalho ela é
quem estava aqui a coisa porque eu todas
as cadeias onde o passado ou eram 55 é
424 4 55 - no meu saque total aquela
pessoa chegou mandou você sabe quando
você joga a culpa à tarde o processo foi
então nunca o chamaram pelo melhor ea
partir daí estamos sim contato com as
pessoas nos olhos não conseguiu fazer
perceber dentro da cadeia
eu tenho também cobrir os meus minha
vida
vocês vão ter 30 mil cliques na equipe
mantendo se a pane
olha estou contente de romã um dos
clientes da minha vida fone eu perdi meu
pai na verdade eu gostei que estava
intenso do governo federal maior caminho
até ao seu povo deve ser um fator local
para coordenar todo dia vai lá fora
os gaúchos não esteja com ela qualquer
um que eu não tenho
foi uma infância perdida no espaço e com
estudo e como isto não conseguem cumprir
realmente aquilo que o fim dessa forma
assim a troca rápida droga é que eu faço
eu tinha medo de contar com até sofrer
mesmo cria então foi contratado por uma
clínica na minha situação melhor na
comunidade terapêutica e assim perceber
quem o som pra onde quer lhe olha que
são os dois médios colecção as meninas
bonitas
o que é que se passou posso dizer que
foi muito mais difícil olhar pra dentro
de dois anos
o campeão da história que eu tenho é de
22 anos eu tenho que olhar pra vencer
drogas e não tinha as minhas corridas em
acordar mas nas páginas posso dizer
quando todos achavam que a vale tem uma
armadura na hora entra e sai do era
assim mas minha eu mas pode ser para a
comunidade
a gordura sai começa a ficar vulnerável
ia tudo sem sentido posso dizer collaço
a mim é uma coisa muito complicada
porque os dez anos que eu fique preso a
viagem o que gerou lá pra mim também deu
da despesa porque eu queria ser lá que
nos próprios pés
ele era cada um com 5 em dizer que acha
então vinha muita dificuldade como o
brasil achava que era coisa séria
ao fim de três meses de tratamento
eu chamei o belo oriente onu disse para
eu preciso falar contigo
então a gente tem que ser em privado ou
explorá lá os porta deslizante não tem
como fazer uma convenção externo no ano
seguinte ele resistiria a derrota não
ficava entre as paróquias da série b eu
ficava ali qualquer coisa chama preso
paulo
tudo que a gente nada eu não to create
sabe o que quero mesmo fazer ficar obra
gostou principalmente também chora
enquanto agora que está a servir
realmente nunca sempre editora natureza
eu realmente acreditei naquilo a que
para tirar a idéia de senhoritas
praticamente estagnada gostei da medida
de moratória é uma chance que nós
aliviar estava afastado para ficar sam
wheat romena laden dose agora dava vaga
que lembrou que ela mesma fica
completamente e atrofiado
bush mas o meu primeiro abraço que daí
entrou melhor coisa que lhe posso dizer
que o brasil concorda eu ser visto
quando a vida piorou mais modificado
quando estava à procura das casas que ao
todo mundo agora quer de vida da sua
frente
antes de pintar o telefone pois nós mais
uma missão de subir
será que vale a pena fazer escadas
será que ela vai nadar será que ela
vende a construir para que as medidas
não é legal fazer o que não vem há algum
tempo à procura da original não suporta
viver combinar autonomia vila cai cai
também estamos dizendo que seja um
aplique sejam vocês como eu estou e 09
nunca gostei de estudar estudar e
estudar como já foi dito aqui que é a
base de tudo
mas atenção cada cidade jogar com outro
convidado e nunca faça o frete da dívida
grega é o seguinte caminho novo um dos
assistentes sociais que fizeram o
correto mas eu sentia a vida ensinou a
certeza da sua génese
já que ele estava era como dizer agora
hoje eu era politicamente correto e
prontos ea minha vida dizia já ganhasse
que tornava fica vez mais a mesma cidade
por isso e hoje saí da casa bastante da
manhã procurando o fotógrafo está em
como abandonar
tem que ter um grupo competitivo é
também parece até um pouco quando eu vou
pra cama eu ia dormir duas horas
gastando 4
mas pelo menos no tranquilo
por isso seja você diz construir nossas
casas
semedo concordado com o conhecimento do
outro e nunca esqueça
vocês são sempre há quem faça por isso
nosso lema é o nosso momento
vamos ver como fazemos com isto
hoje posso dizer que sou sou
extremamente coerente com as casas não
terminada porque a escada no caminho
nunca vocês perguntarem hoje nos canais
né bicho não esperava ter alguns
internet foi saber que a lista era outro
por essa escada nunca também dá porque o
caminho vamos dar espaço na vida as
coisas vão acontecer e eu não estava
ainda não está concluído
só será concluída quando os meus
mentores de tecnologia com o nome dizia
temos 108 177 e esta responsabilidade e
este crescimento do outro vai fazer hoje
e com isto é facilmente depois de a
conquista
de acordo com instalação segnini ia
falando tá aí volta acaba de 81 seu dom
canal
se eu dou outro não saibam fazer com
isso
vocês que estão aí ambos já jogaram não
deixando sempre sonhou com o motor mas
também começou com um ai pensei faça
alguma compensação você vai encontrar o
caminho
com isso muito obrigado a fonte
[Aplausos]
[Música]